let's talk about some young folks now as
some young students that have been on a
career track from a very early age with
clear plans and goals for their working
life but others including many children
of immigrants may not have exposure to
high-powered industries that's where our
unique outreach program is providing
them with both information and
inspiration to make their dreams come
true inside this home in Queens New York
Bengali remains the spoken language but
six years after immigrating to the US
the mem family is living their American
dream through their firstborn of Rina
America we just wanted to have a better
life get a better education for
ourselves that's why I want to be a
Dutch she's got a head start thanks to
legal outreach Tamika Edwards runs the
after-school program our students are
coming from communities where they might
not see a lot of professionals do people
take for granted what you're teaching
here absolutely absolutely you have
parents who are connected to colleges
parents were connected professionally
and our students don't necessarily have
that about 50 high school girls across
New York City apply for summer
internships and receive prep to succeed
all year round these are high school
freshmen who are gonna leave tonight
with contacts at a major law firm in New
York filled with women who want to help
and support them
attorney Lee ago deskey is one of the
volunteers what's the most important
skill set that they take home I think
confidence that's really what we're
looking to instill in these girls so
that when they walk into their
internship or they walk into their first
job interview they're their shoulders
are back their chin is up and they're
looking at someone right in the eye and
ready to grab that position grab that
opportunity and that starts with what a
handshake a handshake right
I like your firm but not too hard
know each other on this night they
practice in the swanky suites of
O'Melveny & Myers a midtown Manhattan
law firm with clients from Ford to
Johnson & Johnson you don't need to
completely do a 180 and change
everything about yourself it's just
little tiny details that you want to pay
attention to to make sure you're putting
forth your best foot and giving someone
the right impression the first time you
meet them what was the most valuable
lesson today
always carry a pen and paper so you have
to write it down because you can't
forget anything
you always should get their business
card and keep in contact with them let's
see your hand show simple answers that
can go a long way how would you describe
the difference Wow it is invaluable it
is invaluable it is remarkable and
remarkable to a 9th grader who quite
literally came the furthest for this
opportunity I'm more confident now and
I'm like outgoing and likes like to talk
to well there's more nothing's gonna
stop you nope that's great to hear
yeah it certainly is and it tells you
something that you know with all the
connections that we have out there yeah
it's like paying it forward
it really makes to do it really does and
some even just a little bit of time a
little bit and the confidence when you
have that moment you know that's huge as
well